all right everybody
welcome to muko's corner where we talk
about
tech and stuff i guess i don't know i
just made the set and i thought it
looked really nice and i feel like maybe
it deserved its own series name or
something
hey everyone how's it going hope you are
well welcome back to my channel where we
talk about
tech career and life today i wanted to
talk about
personal projects personal coding
projects coding
projects personal coding things
today i wanted to talk about personal
projects in software engineering so i'm
putting on an event in october where
everybody works on their personal
projects called code with friends link
in bio and so i wanted to make a video
today about why i think
personal projects are really important
as well as some of my tips and tricks
for working on them
and i thought it would be cool to talk
about personal projects by like
working on a personal project at the
same time
because i thought that could be kind of
meta and instead of coding because that
gets kind of complicated and then i have
to debug and then i'll lose focus
i thought
i could work on a lego project um the
pieces in here are super random and i
actually don't know what i'm gonna make
but at the end of this there will be a
project like a lego project that i
finish
while i talk about personal projects and
also
enjoy my morning cup of coffee so
without further ado
let's talk about where personal products
are important when we're first learning
about programming we often times turn to
tutorials and different blog posts and
stuff for
getting our feet wet with coding which
is great but the best way to
actually build your skills in coding is
to work on your own project
because tutorials are really nice and
all and they tell you exactly what to do
to get to you know an actual product but
doing something from scratch that
doesn't have
any sort of tutorials or guides builds
really important skills to become a
seasoned software engineer
and it's things like being able to read
documentation debugging errors
as well as a skill to actually figure
out how something really works
because in industry no one ever really
tells you exactly how to build the thing
they just kind of expect you to be able
to build it
so learning those skills are really just
an integral part to becoming a good
software engineer
another reason for why personal projects
are really important is because
it's a great way to learn a technology
that maybe you've always wanted to learn
before
like maybe you want to become like a
front-end engineer but you don't really
quite know the difference between
react and view for instance so one thing
that you might work on
is work on a project that just uses vue
and then work on a project that just
uses react
and see how they compare which piece is
supposed to make these wheels work
like for real for real for wheel four
wheels and when you're gonna start
learning something new then always start
with the basics or the foundations of
code or whatever you need to know
although it's a common thing to get
stuck in tutorial land it is a good
place to just at least start to learn
and grasp the concepts of everything
so knowing things like logic algorithms
and data structures are really important
which is where i want to talk about the
sponsor of today's video brilliant
they're a website that has a bunch of
courses in the sciences
their courses are all interactive and so
they're really great for learning those
really important fundamentals and
foundations
to build those computer science skills
on top so go to brilliant.org
hello myuco and sign up for free and the
first 200 people that go to that link
will get 20
off the annual premium subscription
thank you brilliant for sponsoring and
now let's get back to this thing
so yeah the tutorials are really
important but also you do have to move
past the tutorials and actually use
those skills in the real world
because that's where you get to like
play with their technology and kind of
explore different capabilities
which then is exactly how you build the
skills that you can put on your resume
for example
and in kind of like a job hunting
perspective personal projects are a
great way to prove that you can provide
value i don't know what i'm going to do
with these wheels i just don't know how
to use them
see if i'm going to make a car for a
personal project then i might have been
good to actually explore what's in the
box first that i know exactly how these
wheels work
but you know that's the other thing you
don't know exactly how things are going
to work until you actually explore and
try to figure it out on your own because
if i did highlight the tutorial thing
it would make this immensely easier but
i'm not gonna because
i'm trying to build the real lego skills
here today and then
will this fit right here ta-da
i've got wheels parkour parkour
oh that kind of works so anyways back to
my job hunting point
if you actually work on an app that has
real users
then it's a really clear way to show to
employers that what you make
like the coding skills that you use can
be translated into
real value which really that's what
companies are evaluating for when you're
especially going for those interviews
like even if the only real user is you
like maybe you really needed
something and you just built it quickly
because it filled a hole in your life
like that's also a great way to
demonstrate that you can
use your coding skills for something
that provides value into the world and i
think it's also because it's very
different to build something just for
the sake of building it versus building
something that really has
value that someone is going to use
because when you build something that
someone's gonna use you're gonna make
sure it's like good quality like when a
user is actually using it you have to
make sure that it works pretty well like
most of the time and there aren't any
bugs and that it's easy to use
and it behaves in a way that the user
expects
i gotta make a move on with these wheels
i'm just like stuck i have so many
different like wheel parts and i don't
know what to do with them
with the pieces that i have i don't
actually know if i can build anything
meaningful on wheels
okay you know what i am gonna do there's
this little train right here
that is on the box and i'm gonna try
making
kind like this thing because this part
looks kind of too hard so i'm just gonna
make this like
back half of things so in making a
personal project it also helps in the
job hunt
in that you can show what your interest
is to recruiters and other software
engineers
because if you work on like the same
tutorial that everybody else is working
on that it doesn't really show like who
you are
what your interests are or like what
kind of problems you like solving
but if you do show people like hey i'm
really into gaming or like i'm really
into like
bio and medicine specifically about
cancer research then you just kind of
stand out way more amongst
other applicants who've all done kind of
the same projects i know that when i was
on kind of like the hiring side of
things and i was looking at resumes for
a job opening
then seeing that someone worked on a
tool for like their community
or something that really helped them in
their day-to-day life or
you know helped enough like just like
one other person really stood out to me
way more
because i think it demonstrates like a
fundamental skill of caring for others
and being able to empathize with the
user and creating something that you
could be proud of and that people would
find useful
what does this look like oh it's
supposed to be like three
how where am i supposed to find a piece
like that though
how does that work so those are all the
reasons why i think personal projects
can be really valuable
and really important so now let's dive
into my tips so when you're working on
personal projects the most important
thing to remember
is that rome was not built in a day like
as much as you want to be ambitious and
build like the next big thing on the
internet i think you also have to be a
little realistic
like the websites and apps that we use
every day take
months even years to create them and if
you're going to work on a really huge
project especially just by yourself then
it is really easy to get demotivated
just by
the pure amount of work there is to do
so what can be done about this
keep your personal projects really
really small
like i think you can definitely start
off by dreaming big about your project
but you definitely then want to scale
down the feature set or the capabilities
to something that is the minimum viable
product or
mvp literally create a list of all the
things that this thing is supposed to do
and then separate the need to haves
and the knives to have like if you're
building an app that's supposed to show
the air quality index for a given area
then you might want the app to show the
air quality index number
and then be able to enter in a zip code
for example
but it probably doesn't need to show
like all the rest of the weather
conditions or the 10-day forecast for
that area too and the best part about
doing this is that once you've built
your mvp
you don't have to say goodbye to the
nice to haves because once you have that
solid
like working bit of stuff then you can
iterate on it and add those nice
halves back in to create a really
compelling project so like now maybe you
have a list of things
that are like that absolutely need to
have
how do you actually go about building it
well my tip is to do a bit of project
planning because again this has
a lot to do with making sure that you
keep up your motivation
and you have momentum so once you have
your must-have
tasks then i really recommend going
through and estimating how long
or how complex something is to build now
this part's really tricky because
we as humans are terrible at estimating
and in reality we don't know how long
something is gonna take until we've done
it
and because you and i are probably not
time travelers we really just only have
our best guess
so yeah just use clues that maybe you
already have like for instance
how long did it take you to build
something similar before
and honestly a rule of thumb that i like
to follow is to
take the number that you have whether
that be hours or days or weeks or maybe
complexity
double it and then add one i know it
kind of seems like overkill like that
really inflates the number to something
huge
but because again we're really bad at
estimating things
it gives us a little bit of flexibility
for when something goes wrong or maybe
we've mis-estimated something and i
always think it's better to
under-promise and over-deliver so
if you end up not taking that much time
then great you're ahead of the game so
after you've estimated everything
i really recommend laying out your
development into phases
so whether you organize your tasks into
this is what i'm doing this week
this is what i'm doing next week and the
rest of this
is for next month now you know exactly
what you're supposed to be doing
at any given time because then all of a
sudden this mountain of work that we had
feels a little bit more manageable
because you have a ton of tiny little
steps to get to where you want to go
and it's okay if the deadline slips like
we're all human
like it's not a big deal like i thought
i was gonna be done with this lego piece
a lot sooner but you know what we're
here and i'm still doing it
but it's coming together pretty good i
would say it's it's
it's getting there now my last step for
working on a personal project
is to use version control now i'm
guessing a lot of y'all are probably
going to work on your projects
just by yourself say you're thinking
like why do i need version control
especially if i'm not working on it with
other people
well you are going to work on it with
yourself
and previous versions of yourself so
version control is really there to help
you
from yourself oh and if you're not
familiar with how version control or git
works then i did a video with microsoft
a while ago
to talk about git workflows to give you
a brief overview because so because
version control allows you to have like
a history of
things that you did and it's basically
just kind of a log you can basically
undo any mistakes that you make
which if you're working on a personal
project especially with something that
doesn't have a spec
or a tutorial or especially if you're
working on a new technology for the
first time
it's really important because everybody
makes mistakes
and projects don't always turn out to be
how you want them to be and so being
able to undo those things to a previous
clean version
is gonna save you a lot of headache i
know it's helped me a lot in the past
because i'll get to a point where i'm
just like
i have completely ruined this project
and there's a point of no return
and then just being able to like go back
to your previous commit
and just undo all of that and start
fresh is just like
it's a relieving feeling okay so i'm
gonna finish my little project here
because i'm like
nearly done and i feel pretty good about
it and i think it's very close
scott can you help me look for a three a
three yeah
i need something that looks like this
but it's
three i guess things don't exist in lego
world
this is something that i've learned by
not using a tutorial but actually just
working on things by myself
yeah i did it here's my completed
product
everybody it's got a lot of windows
it's got wheels
yay yeah personal project done
and this is because i decided to be
realistic about what i can make
still right up into issues didn't use a
tutorial
[Music]
all right everybody i hope you like this
video about coding and personal projects
and muko's corner where she plays with
legos and explains something about
software engineering
if you like this video then make sure to
subscribe i make videos about tech
and career and lifestyle and stuff and
let me know what tips you have for
working on personal projects in the
comments down below
i'll see you next time and take care
everybody bye